Andre Dell isn't getting out of prison
anytime soon an attempt by the West
Coast rapper known as Mac minister to
get his murder conviction tossed out
failed Clark County District Court Judge
Michelle Levitt denied his request after
hearing hours of testimony
murder and
um conspiracy to Commitment two Council
conspiracy commit murder they gave me
four lives without the possibility of
parole Dow was convicted in 2008 for a
double murder in Las Vegas in 2005. the
victims Kansas City rappers Anthony
Fatone Watkins and Jermaine Cowboy
Aikens how did they end up murdered in
your girlfriend's car
I don't have no answer for that Dell
spoke with the 8 news now investigators
from prison several times in 2022 he
also participated in podcasts which
judge Levitt refers to in her order Dao
insisted witness Antoine Mouton lied
judge Levitt writes Dow posted mouton's
personal information and talked about
how he testified against him on a
podcast two days later Mouton filled out
a document changing his story the judge
questions mouton's motivation and
credibility someone here in Las Vegas
helped you prepare this affidavit I
really don't ask too many questions
I decided to look into it judge Levitt
also calls out this former San Francisco
prosecutor in her order Latif gray says
he started looking into the Nevada case
after he heard Dao on a podcast do you
believe he's 100 innocent based on this
evidence I do gray claims he key
uncovered information which he believes
prosecutors withheld judge Levitt calls
some of his testimony here inaccurate
and points out how he knew Dao since
they grew up in the same neighborhood
something we previously asked gray about
it's irrelevant
a prosecutor recently admitted he made a
mistake during the trial at least twice
when referring to a time frame but judge
Levitt also writes Dal failed to prove
prosecutors withheld information from
the defense and she calls his fight
untimely since it's 11 years later
Vanessa Murphy 8 news now and Vanessa
reached out to Andre Dow's attorney
Robert DeMarco he said he is
disappointed in the judge's decision and
that thou is evaluating his legal
remedies he expects he will appeal the
judge's ruling